at the Everett's write something Alaba
Thank You Bradley now you've been
dancing with Beyonce since you were 17
years old yes and here you are 10 years
later her dance captain you performed
around the world the Super Bowl twice
all right I mean when you look back on
this past decade like for the meet you
oh my gosh well it has definitely helped
shape and mold the woman I am now
because I was I was a girl when I
started you know and now I'm grown and
you know she's just been such a huge
inspiration in my life and so many
others obviously because you had to make
a choice right you were young like I'd
be able to stick with the object yeah it
was like okay good I quit the door and
go to school and keep training or do I
just start my career and I gotta do it
right I mean the average job Peter yeah
I can't be hearing me not learn some
choreography from one of me on face
videos so what we learned today
well we're gonna do a little love on top
it's only right you know love is in the
air at village so let the love is in the
air okay I'm going to tell you right now
I actually might be pretty good
obviously I'm a quick learner but and
take it away we'll see they say love
hurts we do a pot of the rich one more
time all right that's right
all right left right yeah okay and then
we twist this round - sniffs oh yeah
okay okay okay all right okay what's
next so we did these snaps three five
six seven eight we do the cheese two
three four to run top top top and hence
head so from there the chorus comes in
we go baby it's used in rock yep
one two right left okay then we thicken
up we fly back up and again program oh
yeah fly okay to catch that cat and look
look you see her just a little doodoo
click clear right yeah yes we go usable
you know on a little thing so you do
your own kind of playing you
oh yeah business so we crossed out up
down yep to click and we totally
disrespected my video please anybody go
and then we'll call always talk make
everything stop yep yeah I'm really
using my mouse on the top and then we do
it again do it again yeah it's like the
same whoo but a lot it's a lot
Hey hello circle to snap a snap hey
thank you run a special maybe issues
right let's study I want to do a double
time actually quit so let's just finish
with and calmly make everything stop
[Music]
all right yeah I feel like I'm in the
video and then she drops the mic it
reveals her pregnancy hey she's like yes
I was there
you are the girl yeah you're bowling
epic moments have to happen on a stage
guys are like that pregnancy engagement
alone again get a mixer I see on her
right now a good mom and I was filming
right now you found I know well no I
know I got a new party trick
yes thanks for watching ET on YouTube
but wait wait wait before you go there's
plenty more where that came from
all you got to do is hit the subscribe
button